the former prime minister has declared
earnings of almost 5 million pounds
since stepping down from Downing Street
in speeches and book deals let's talk
about it in more detail Andrew Jameson
has written about Boris and he's with us
now good morning do you know that about
Turner case I did actually because I
just been reading about Nelson who lost
his right arm and he the tourniquet
which was a minister odd left by his
stepson saved his life yes but it was
and it was a well he's been shot in the
elbows it had to be above the elbow I
guess okay there you go obviously but I
wouldn't have spotted it
I didn't know that um I wonder if Boris
Johnson would have spotted he's a very
clever man to the extent that he's
earned almost 5 million quid already
since he left um dining Street he's not
very good on medical things I think no
he's earning a lot of money though smart
yes some of it's in advance I mean in
advance for speeches and an advance for
book but yes I think it's rather I'm
rather worried that the other MPS are
earning so little I mean they're not
they're not giving him any kind of
competition we should have I mean we
should have some real top earners in
Parliament I mean very gifted people who
can earn lots of money in other fields
as well as politics do you think he's a
gifted person yeah how probably he is
he's a very gifted speaker and he's been
doing that very successfully since about
the age of 16. he's practiced actually
should he be giving the sort of speeches
that he's giving
um for money or should he be doing it in
the House of Commons well he should do
both but I see no objection although I
watched the one he gave the soft power
Summit it seemed to go down very badly
with the audience I wasn't actually in
the audience they didn't laugh or clap
or share at all because I think they
were all they were all remainers and he
was talking about leave and Liberty and
freedom and people who have time to go
to that kind of conference maybe they
don't have a tremendous Instinct for
Liberty and freedom yeah but it was
about the Northern Ireland protocol yes
it was you know you said it's some
important stuff yes maybe he should have
been doing that in the House of Commons
I don't think
it it I I mean of course
um he always wants to have his cake and
eat it but I think actually doing stuff
outside the House of Commons gives you a
I mean I don't mean particularly
necessarily that conference but it gives
you a bit more of an idea of what the
hell's going on in the outside world so
I think I think it's a good thing for
MPS to have other occupations which
whether whatever it may be so they're
actually involved in in other aspects of
life we were certainly led to believe
when he was in number 10 that he was
desperate for cash strapped needed to
get loans all sorts of things yes you
know obviously you've written about him
how do you think he will how do you
think he will be reconciling the fact
now that my goodness I can earn all this
money well it enables them to to Harbor
the ambition of becoming prime minister
again because then he'll he'll have hay
in the barn as one of his supporters put
it so yeah he's getting ready this isn't
just money for the sake of money it's
money so that he has is it Liberty to
continue doing politics many years ago
he have decided to that he would just be
a very very highly paid journalist in
television and newspapers and he didn't
he went on doing that he he is very
highly paid a journalism but he he took
the trouble and the time and it's a hell
of a lot of time
to become an MP and then to become mayor
of London and then subsequently prime
minister via foreign secretary Etc but
um do you think he has a chance of being
prime minister again he obviously thinks
he does I think he I think he's piling
up again
part of the charm of of his career or
the channel of writing about it is it
has been one astonishment after another
it's very very unpredictable I I can't
see how he can possibly become Prime
Minister again in this Parliament
because 148 of his own MPS voted against
him only last June when there was a
confidence motion and then 60 members of
the government resigned and more would
have resigned if he hadn't got the
message so I and one of the essential
functions of whoever leads the Tory
party is to United he can't unite it in
this Parliament but if they do if they
have a real smash of the next election
which is what the polls say they're
heading for uh then you know he's he's
he's still a big figure and of course
he'll be in with a chance he might lose
his seat he might lose his seat but you
it's quite easy to provide I mean it's
quite easy I mean lots of associations
will be delighted and someone would step
down and go to the House of Lords and so
he could have he could get into
by-election maybe go back to Henley or
wherever which is he might go back to
Henley yes okay that's possible you say
that he he divides the party but I mean
100 am I right saying 106 of them voted
for him and to potentially be the next
prime minister when he was up could have
been up against Rishi sunak and then he
decided not to stand yes it was it was
too soon but of course he I think he's
very he's very cunning
person and he but he also knows that
it's an absolutely essential to show
keenness otherwise people think well
he's given up he's just going to go and
write books and give speeches and he's
not interested so he showed he was
interested and he and he showed that he
does as you say he has very very
uh some very he still has some very very
devoted supporters who think that he's a
much bigger figure and who also think I
mean you you wouldn't be able to do this
okay but I can I can think my way into
the mindset of a third rate Tori MP who
knows that he's unemployable in any
other capacity and that he's not going
to be paid 5 million quid to gives
features
um if they lose their seat that's it
that's the end of their the terrible
blow to the both of the finances and to
their self-esteem and Boris Johnson
showed
shown repeatedly that he is the greatest
campaigner the conservatives have gotten
that he makes that connection
uh and and he's and he's now once more
able to play the game which is his
natural game he's the Insurgent he's the
person who shocks The Establishment and
the more shocked the establishment is
the more a certain kind of voter laughs
and thinks oh yes he's the man for me do
you think given everything you've said
that he could be prime minister again
he could be yes
do you think he will be
I would say there's about
uh
two in five chance I would say that's
high the 40 chance yes but is that's a
complete guess actually I should I
should add that I am always wrong
I know I'm not meant to say I meant to
come you know pretend I'm the great
Authority but I'm not it's good to see
you thanks for joining us on the program
much appreciated thanks